c'est une autre vie telnic à une autre
une perte mais c'était en fait pour être
normal la vie soit plus gai et la vie
sera bien plus facile à 2 j'aime pas me
marier quoi j'aime rester seul quoi
comme ça s'amuse mais quoi quand on est
trop jeune ça sert à rien faut bien se
marier et même h&o faudra attendre
d'abord le temps l'aja c'est bien beau
quoi sur moi au début
après ces patients selon le mariage
c'est formidable chez marie un certain
âge qui sert à rainures le centre
féminin avec le sexe masculin
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je comprends
pas c'est une bonne chose dans certains
cas puis son nez
du moins bon dans d'autres ça dépend
on se rend avec la famille qu'on aime et
puis c'est bien le mariage et vous
monsieur que pensez-vous du mariage je
le dis fais pas dire cet enfant enfin
sans doute sans doute mais vous allez
bien une opinion là-dessus jeune homme
avez vous lu molière dyana gaye et bien
j'en pense ce qu'on pensait molière
monsieur c'est à dire des tas de choses
et souvent contradictoires monsieur
enfin oui ou non de lier répugne était
au mariage
[Musique]